i was watching um a documentary about
not just about you but the whole sort of
movement in the 90s with music you know
it was really fascinating
it was that uh mother love bone right uh
band that was like huge there
yeah their lead singer died and yeah he
was my roommate yeah andy yeah and it
sounded to me like andy was incredible
he he um he inspired a lot of that
period of kind of commercial metal bands
right um
mother love bone i actually feel like
was the bridge between
that comma that period of commercial
metal and nirvana for example
right it was the bridge yeah and the
fact that andy did died
that bridge kind of vanished so that guy
was when you were
first starting out and you were with
soundgarden
i was with soundgarden he was in a band
called malfunction with
um with his best friend regan hagar and
his brother who was a guitar player who
was incredibly good
and he was the big star in that whole
seattle scene yeah andy was uh yeah he
was very
you know if you get if you take two
steps outside of seattle it's a very
conservative
kind of right-wing place and andy back
then
had like long blonde hair down to his
ass
and he would wear kind of white face
kind of kiss makeup
right and he would play a purple bass um
and he would wear a spandex uh but but
their songs almost sounded like
they sounded like discharge like punk
rock it was unlike anything you'd ever
seen it was very aggressive
but he was very effeminate and very
showy he just loved elton john and
freddie mercury and
he loved that that persona of just being
over the top he had kind of an entourage
he would walk around you know when
knowing who he was did you envy him
because you are an artist and you said
[ __ ] he's the guy who's going to make it
i don't know if we are but he's going to
make it
i learned a lot from him in terms i
envied his ability to do anything
um in terms of songwriting performing
it didn't seem like he had that voice in
the back of his head saying
um uh this probably sucks you're not
you're an idiot
if he believed it he valued his own
opinion exactly he didn't really seem to
pause
and check himself and say is this okay
to do or not and i think that's why
everyone was so drawn to him
wouldn't it be great to be an artist
like that where you could say you know
what
everyone else's opinion just doesn't
matter to me what i think is good
is what's going on that record that
would be the ultimate wouldn't it be
it would
so this is a guy that would have been a
huge star in your opinion that he's one
of these guys we don't know about but we
would have loved
well he um mother loved one was him and
and also uh stone gossard from
pearl jam and jeff ayman from pearl jam
uh and
they were a great songwriting team as
well are you still friends with the
pearl jam dudes and i i just i just
picture all you guys knew each other
because you played the same clubs and
everything
are you good friends with the eddie
vetter and those characters yeah
we we just did some temple of the dog
things at their uh they did they did the
summer festival it was great uh
celebrating their 20-year anniversary
so everybody stays in touch yeah
you